could babylon 5 be snatched from the cw
network to join one of the big streaming
services
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv movie
channel
so to explain this story i have to go
back a little bit so as we know babylon
5 was in early production michael j
strzinski has written a pilot a pilot
that the cw are apparently very happy
with and we're all prepared to start
filming
in the last couple of months
but the cw unexplicably and suddenly
decided to actually put this on hold for
at least a year
they say they don't want to start
production on this big project until the
cw sale has been completed and the dust
is settled
but does that make total sense or is
there something else going on we have to
understand for one why the cw's being
sold it's currently owned by cbs and
warner brothers and warner brothers is
owned by att
att their big telecommunications company
wants to come back to its roots and
concentrate on its core business
obviously telecommunications
they don't want to necessarily be in the
entertainment business that much anymore
so they have decided to sell the bulk of
their stake in the cw and cbs are going
along with that they will both still be
minor shareholders within the cw and
they will still produce material for the
cw but they will no longer be the 50 50
owners they are today 18t are also doing
something else so that's very
interesting with hbo max
they are actually stepping away from
that also but they're not selling their
steak because the mom that's warner
brothers who own that
warner brothers and the discovery
network discovery inc are actually
becoming merged and they will become a
separate entity on their own separated
from a t
david suslav which is currently the ceo
of discovery will become the ceo of this
new company and he's already talking
about how hbo max was going to be pushed
forwards that is going to be a very
ambitious project over the next 12
months that they're ramping up
expenditure and they're going to have
some new big stories to tell them so
does that mean they could poach pablo 5
from the cw well i have people i talk to
that work within the industry and
they're telling me that conversations
have already happened
and that's actually the biggest reason
why the cw decided not to push forward
bubble of five because they know chances
are it's going to end up on hbo max
instead
but why would hbo max be doing this well
at the end of the day they're in a war
right now with amazon prime disney plus
and netflix there's a struggle for who
is going to exert dominance in this new
streaming field that netflix actually to
be fair has dominated for the last
nearly a decade
dave zaslav has already announced that
next year's production budget for new
content for hbo max is going to be 20
billion dollars to put that into context
last year amazon actually spent 13
billion on new content now i expect that
figure to go up this year because mainly
because of lord of the rings
but also netflix only spent 14 billion
on new content and that doesn't look
like that's going to increase disney
actually spend 30 billion a year on new
content but that is not just new content
for disney plus so actually as a
production cost for just disney plus
alone they don't actually spend anywhere
near that much
hbo are going to be from at least a
spending point of view
the industry leader they're going to be
spending more on new content than
anybody else
now jms does have a close working
relationship with pedowitz who is the
ceo of the cw and it's fair to say as
well the pedot is a big fan of babylon
5. babylon 5 used to be on the
predecessor to the cw network and jms
does have an element of loyalty to that
but at the end of the day jameis is
going to want to produce the best tv
show he can and hbo max will be able to
spend a lot more money on babylon 5 than
the cw could ever dream of the map that
seriously mentioned the warner brothers
actually did co-produce babylon 5
originally with babylonian pictures
for the original series
that was also the plan for this series
the warner brothers would again
co-produce so warner brothers are going
to really want to put this show where it
can have the most impact and is felt by
industry insiders that the most impact
it can have on is hbo max a streaming
service
it should be mentioned that in america
there has been a big shift away from
cable networks onto streaming five or
six years ago nearly 80 percent of
households in the united states had
cable services that number is now
actually a lot closer to 50 percent and
dropping every year
more and more people are cutting the
cables and switched into streaming
services
also when people in the united states
are asked about their streamer services
they say that they have every intention
of keeping the stream of services and in
fact intend to add to them over the next
12 months so streamer services really is
the future and networks like the cw
the past
so if you're warner brothers and you've
got a new big project that you have and
already a fan base for and you want to
put it on the best place where you can
earn the biggest bang for your dollar
where are you going to put it you're
definitely going to put it on hbo max
hbo max
is pushing towards 900 million
subscribers and actually want to push
this network worldwide babylon 5 would
be a great tv show to have in this
stable and again give you access to a
whole new slurry of subscribers
so what do you think guys would you
prefer to see babylon 5 on the cw where
it may not get the same investment but
at least you can watch it for free
or would you rather it actually got a
bigger investment but then you have to
subscribe to hpr max to actually watch
it it means you might have to put your
hand in your pocket but it might mean
you get a better funded and better
quality tv show at the end of it
i'm absolutely certain jms given the
choice would switch to ho max because
even if he is loyal to the cw he's more
loyal to producing a good tv show and he
has more likelihood of doing that if
he's got more money to spend so guys
come on what do you think leave me a
comment
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can become a fully fledged side
tracker please hit the join button as
always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time